[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
yagg
il doit faire un toc toc toc venez on
fait une barre car on n'était jamais
rentré faire l'émission avec moi
aujourd'hui y en a chez rim étoiles à
aller vadim étoiles à mes toiles à
monthois la magie mais toi
[Applaudissements]
toi bien là vient la vache c'est parti
[Musique]
j'aime bien alors on aime bien le cuir
apparemment alors je peux demander
c'est là d'ailleurs est-ce que tu as que
tu as quelque chose à dire à ton amour
bien sûr mais révisé m'a dit qu'ils
révisent le conducteur
à l'ouest encore un jour
[Musique]
et vous allez me dire si vous voulez que
je conserve les chroniqueurs tels quels
ou si vous voulez qu'on fasse un toc toc
toc avec les chroniqueurs qui sont ces
discussions de safer sa part d'audience
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'ai un beau gosse sur google books
là hélas hélas tu prends compan talent
enfin l'asie l'arrivée de votre tendance
haussière alors on va faire ça du coup
bah si sinon je me fasse pareil au
niveau bas de ce face à face à face du
nord en descente et tu tires comme sa
jeunesse en quoi tu prends ça en terrain
et quand tu te trompes tu ne tire pas en
avant d'autres titres comme ça vers le
bas rhin est il n'enfreint pas les plus
belles pas tué a plaidé pour la légende
la chanteuse est en marche et vous êtes
vous fait quand c'est bon on se met en
route un petit tour du zoo et là on fait
trop fine et là tu as fait
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je vis